[Music]
in book prediction news oh my god is
this Game of Thrones
he's a Nostradamus submitted by suck
that mother [ __ ] dad what a papa suck
that [ __ ]
okay suck on some conspiracy theories
about the quote rise and fall of Donald
Trump have arisen from obscure books
written in a 19th century Oh like
foreshadowing did people predict that
Donald's gonna be president I like the
name Donald because Donald Duck
I think Melania should write a tell-all
book exposing him but she's so dumb is
Melania dumb and she just got caught
like plagiarizing Michelle Obama's
speech but what if she was forced to do
that she's like I don't want to copy her
speech and in Donald's like no no honey
you just people are gonna make fun of me
that's the point
do you wanted wanna talk I think I think
they did that she's like oh don't make
me do this and he's like no come on you
gotta do it honey do it she does not
want this first lady role at all she's
[ __ ] do you think that they have some
sort of contract or agreement that if
she leaves him or it gets fat and ugly
then he like I don't know kills her
family or like takes a little money from
her or something I think she's the
pretty first lady so grandma looking
except for Michelle yoked yeah her arms
were set mm-hmm
so it's cool mm-hmm but I'm just saying
just write a tell-all book
millions of people buy it I know it's
funny um you know how like weird ass
like super right conspiracy theories
they think Michelle Obama is actually a
man and Obama is like super gay stupid
yeah because Michelle Obama's so like
fit they can't believe that she's a
woman she's still feminine
their own wives are like satin can't see
them but that's how [ __ ] crazy people
are like they make up some [ __ ] they're
like yeah do you hear what they're
making up now okay so there's this book
by author Ingersoll Lockwood who spelled
Ingersoll ing ers OLM inner soul yes
interesting people really hate their
kids I know a couple trouble cliff so he
wrote this book back in 1893 called
Baron Trump's marvelous underground
journey
do you know Baron Trump and his son yeah
oh so mo Trump's son and this was
written before he was even born
1893 what whoa but there's a small
difference in the spelling of the name
so in the book it's double horse single
wrong is e ro n and Donald Trump's son
is with double ORS I mean is it cuz like
you know it's like the name John Smith
or whatever you know how it's super
common John Doe don't know any burns
yeah I mean but names I feel like they
cycle in and out sometimes they're like
like ink no not in grits but you know
like those old school names and then
he's gonna back off Gertrude's oh my god
Kircher or truths you know but that was
a popular or like how about like Steve
Wynn at least 6 billion of them because
of this book it's proof that that the
past predicted the future well what's
the other thing is to this same author
he published his other book called 1900
or the last president so in these two
books there's a lot of similarities to
the present time so for example in Baron
Trump's marvelous underground journey
there they're saying that this mystical
guide or the the person that guides loot
this little kid through Russia his name
is dawn so that's like really similar
right to Donald Trump that is
Donald loves Russia maybe that's his
favorite book so in a story they're
talking about how this little boy and
his dog
leave Castle Trump and on to a journey
underground and then finally when they
meet dawn he's reminded of the Trump
motto which is the path weights of glory
is strewn with pitfalls and dangers so
the book mentions that there is a Fifth
Avenue Hotel that will be the first to
feel the fury of the mob after this
election by this president that's
supposed to liberate the people from the
bankers which is an anti-establishment
candidate which Trump was here Wow did
the mob take over is it one of those
hotels yes all Fifth Avenue is where
Trump Tower is oh [ __ ] there's so many
similarities from those books to what's
happening now but Snopes ended up being
bunking some of these things but you
have the smoke just a conjecture what
site Oh
why were they saying these book is not
that Oh somebody made this [ __ ] up no
they're saying that all these claims are
mostly true but is just skewed like all
these people with these conspiracy
theories it kind of like conveniently
like immediately they're gonna stretch
the facts a little bit too much they're
like there's a pigeon in his book and
there's a pigeon on Trump Tower he's
like so yeah like for example a baron
Trump that's not really his name his
name
so Baron means like a lord yeah so
they're calling him like Lord cholo out
of the tribe I always think Baron as in
like bear oh really had like you're
barren like you can't okay well I
spelled different yeah baron i also
bears like a royal despotic
like you can Duchess yes like Duke love
a [ __ ] Duke bad no the difference is
Lord Duke and I like when you get
knighted you're sir yes sir Joseph clean
gone
now insert one Kong protector of the
dollies I took you know like that and
then Don in the book he's actually a
Spaniard so it's like Don Harmon it's
like a really long Don Quixote what
would they say what would their title be
cuz you know like they've got medieval
times there too yeah what's so like I
don't know you know got me of all times
we're met in a Spain I don't know about
Spanish [ __ ] you speak a Spanish I mean
[ __ ] I know more ass okay it is the
responsibility of Mexicans to know both
native history as well as Spanish
history it is your guys's [ __ ] you need
to learn about Chiclets
and you need to learn about trumpets
don't blame it on the frijoles yeah so
on 4chan and reddit they were talking
about this entire conspiracy thing and
something that was pretty interesting
was how on 4chan they wrote this after
Nikola Tesla's death the FBI ordered
alien property custodian to seize
Tesla's belongings even though Tesla was
an American citizen the National Defense
Research Committee called in an MIT
professor to make sense of Tesla's notes
in order to analyze if anything in them
could be weaponized that MIT professor
was John Trump which is Donald Trump's
uncle so they are saying in this 4chan
thread that that uncle actually
discovered Tesla's like time travel
secrets and he actually created a time
travel machine and that true then try
going back in time and rewriting history
or supposedly that Trump went back in
time and he saw a future where it was
like completely destroyed and he felt
that in order to save the future he had
to become president and do all this
stuff and in this book is part of it
somehow I think they that's so cool
copies are Superman Trump to the rescue
I'm gonna save the way
that's my 10 threaded things awesome
some people's minds are crazy cuz
they're like mixing reality with fiction
and those dinosaurs and then these Ninja
Turtles came out of nowhere but is part
of is part of saving history being
really dumb you know what's crazy though
like people they have such a wild
imagination but then there's a lot of
variables in the world where like
there's a chance that that imagination
can happen 300 years later yeah like all
the sci-fi movies where people kind of
like uh what if there's this thing that
you can just talk into and then you can
see your friend and then yeah we're like
there's just yeah there's so many
technological things in the movies that
came true like thirty years later or
whatever still waiting for my hoverboard
though that is something I'm they use a
hoverboard this is just on wheels I like
to tell actually I like thinking about
how like back then back in like eighteen
hundred's whatever they're like damn
it's good to live in modern times I
can't I don't know how they lived in the
Stone Age when they didn't have paper
these hats that [ __ ] on rock I know and
they thought they were [ __ ] back then
and then now we're probably thinking
about now but in like [ __ ] six
hundred years from now and they're gonna
be like oh [ __ ] they typed on computers
think yeah stupid we think it but break
the brain man it's also assuming the
world still gonna exist at that point
sure hope you guys enjoyed that video
but if you didn't guess what you can
directly contribute to the articles that
we discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up hey
[Music]